vladimir putin warned the west on
wednesday not to cross
russia's red line says moscow would
respond swiftly and harshly to any
provocations and those responsible would
regret it at a time of acute crisis and
ties with the united states and europe
the russian troops masses
mass near ukraine and opposition leader
alexey navalny
on hunger strike in jail the kremlin
leader used the state
of the nation's speech to project a
message of russian strength and defiance
in the face of outside
threats putin who is 68 and has
dominated russia for two decades made no
mention of navalny
washington last week tightened sanctions
on russia accusations of computer
hacking
and election interference and the czech
republic accused moscow over rolling
explosions
at an arms depot in 2014 both expelled
russians diplomats russia denied
wrongdoing and responded with
tit-for-tat expulsions
i'm going to read the next part then i'm
going to give it to you here on navalny
dozens of
uh naval news supporters the rest of the
day of a protest against
vladimir putin this is a newsweek story
police in russia started making an
arrest early wednesday a day uh
when protests in support of jailed
opposition figure alexi navalny are
expected to draw tens of thousands of
people in the streets of the country
there was an urgency to the scheduling
of the protest of navalny due to his
reported
faltering health which has generated
international concerns so
adam you look like got something to say
about this go ahead no i don't know how
much time we have left but
look this guy lexi navalny is a serious
guy man okay
this is a guy who was if you ever seen
that
video of him being poisoned on an
airplane oh
damn he's dying on a plane he leaves the
country ends up in germany
uh recovers recuperates goes back to ger
back to russia he could have just left
the country and never came back because
he knew what he was in for
he said i'm going back gets jailed
he's in jail for however long he's
this guy's he's a serious dude he's got
some serious balls here
and he's going against putin i know
you're a big fan of putin i'm not
putting words in your mouth but
that you respect putin a lot i told you
that you did win
the last time i saw you when i said when
you said the beach it was no longer but
you said you respect
putin more than biden i said that yes
why did i say that i don't know you're
gonna about that you're good about to
speak but
this guy putin he's a murderer he's a
thug uh and a lot of people do respect
him because he's a
tough guy um but the world is watching
and now this guy's at a hunger strike
and um we'll see what happens here so
i got respect for this guy navalny he's
i don't know what he's doing
and then regarding um what's going on in
crimea
the analogy here with crimea is russia
cares about this
beyond it's kind of like how china cares
about taiwan
what's going on what's that no go ahead
keep going i heard him go ahead you got
you got
all sorts of hearing um
anyway this guy is legit and i don't i
this guy's about to die more than likely
he's not a hunger strike he's
being jailed he's i don't know
how much longer he's got left that's my
concern where are you at
um i'm with you as far as him going
and then coming back he obviously had a
point to prove
and yeah he is on the hunt i read up on
a little bit yesterday uh
but i mean at the end of the day here's
here's what it comes down to uh you know
we're talking about martyrs earlier
right so what do you think what do you
think he wants to be a martyr for
nova this guy what do you think he wants
to be murdered for
in your opinion like he's wanting to be
like murder likely the corruption
and the uh everything that's surrounding
putin and
everything that he stands for okay so
what do you think about putin them
saying that he's fine that he's
perfectly fine that he's good
can you trust that whatsoever that's
like when china says anything how can
you trust them
okay so what it comes down to is
it it comes out to something very very
very very simple it's not
difficult to to look at it or to have a
different perspective on it
when poon is in a position to where he
can
expose him and say hey he's fine right
because that's what he's saying
right that's what the government's
saying if i'm mistaken that he's good
right or am i
i'm a mistake yeah i guess he's on a
hunger strike he's dying in prison
he's fine yeah if he's fine then show
him to the public
bring him on and show him that he's fine
right to to discredit
all because you're trying to discredit
him right that's what they're trying to
do
so he's trying to discredit food well
boone's also trying to discredit him
that's why he has them locked up so show
that he's fine bring him out
and show the world because it's a world
story you guys are on the same page on
this
uh to a certain extent yeah yes or no
yeah i think i'm on team navalny not i'm
not
that's what he's done no i'm not a putin
fan
i never told you that i never maybe you
were emotional
no i i've no i don't know bro you said
you liked it let
let me clear that up this is the way i
talk
there's not emotion i i come from a loud
ass mexican family
people like you talk people not be
emotional but you're emotional no no i
don't know how they speak in your house
but in my house everybody when we have a
dinner speaks over each other
that's just the way it is this is the
way i talk have you met alejandro or no
i have not the same by the way even
maybe i'm even more animated
yes yes yeah stands up and runs around
and he'll he's like people are my
brother yeah yeah brother
like but i make like i look forward to
meeting your brother i make logical like
i make logical points but this is people
like it's funny because i always
even when i do lives you're talking
people don't have to be emotional but
you're emotional i don't know how it is
in your household
but in my household everybody yells
i'm cool with no reason exactly don't
apologize to me bro
oh you're not all trust me i plan trust
me i have zero plans of apologizing to
you
okay now what i'm getting at is that
just for the viewers this is the way we
talk in my house
you talk to my wife my mom's my wife 300
bucks would you apologize
no i would never apologize to you for
anything not even 300
but what i'm getting at is i want 700
more in quarters ricardo i got you don't
worry about it what are you gonna do
with those quarters i'm actually so
curious what you're gonna do with that
by the way let's say
laundry day okay so let's uh uh by the
way do you have any takes on navalny and
putin and what's going on in the
restaurant i would say that's the part
about america where at least we have the
ability to see what the alternative
option is and we decide okay that
in russia you don't really have that
because you don't have a lot of options
he tells you i'm going to be here for a
while you can't do nothing about it and
russians kind of say okay
that's where we're going that's the
difference between what we still have in
america
and what some other countries don't have
it's the benefit of how america was
founded on so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]